609 on your Friday morning so much going
on if you don't normally hang out in
downtown Las Vegas but you're thinking
about going there this weekend you need
to know there are signs like this all
over the area
the first event is a 5K race through the
downtown area starting at five tomorrow
evening and although many of the
affected streets won't officially be
closed until 4 30. don't be surprised to
find tricky conditions starting earlier
than that
then the bigger races the 10K and the
Half Marathon they start at 4 30 Sunday
afternoon on the strip between Flamingo
and Tropicana you need to know that many
I-15 Freeway exits from trop all the way
up to Charleston well they're going to
be closed starting at 2 30 in the
afternoon running until as late as 10 30
Sunday night and the Half Marathon will
tie up Las Vegas Boulevard all the way
up to the Fremont Street Experience
obviously a lot of signs and warnings
for drivers about the races but please
spread the word to anybody you think
might need to know now we do have the
online version of this story with links
to the running website 8newsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully put down that
phone join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com